Hunter Biden getting bailed out again by
his dad a whistleblower says a corrupt
first son receiving special treatment in
his tax probe an IRS agent who oversees
criminal investigations claims the bond
Administration is mishandling the case
against Hunter and that there's a clear
conflict of interest the agent is
seeking whistleblower protections and
his attorney says he's willing to spill
all the beans to Congress
my client wants to come forward to
Congress he's ready to be questioned
about what he knows and what he
experienced under the proper legal
protections would you find any evidence
or allegation of a political agenda no
to him the truth is one truth and he
wants to come forward with it the things
he's been through are are very well
documented in emails and other
Communications with the Department of
Justice
of course the White House given us this
valuable Insight here
[Laughter]
I want to be very
here as you know the president respects
the rule of law and and the depend the
independence of the Department of
Justice he believes that's what they
should be in this Administration we
believe that it should be independent so
I'm not going to go beyond that does the
White House support giving this IRS
agent
state of transparency and so that we do
not politicize any of this the president
has been very clear that this is
something for the Department of Justice
which is independent
yeah okay but a top Democrat has taken
it very seriously
I concur with the belief that there
should be no interference in these
investigations we take all
whistleblowers statements seriously as
we should some turn out to be very
important and some not but we take them
all seriously at the outset and look at
them closely judge it looks like this
whistleblower is taking a lot of
precaution he's not even sharing
everything with his lawyer trying to
make sure he protects himself he doesn't
want to get persecuted here I remember
when some whistleblowers in the Trump
administration were held as Heroes what
do you think is going on for Hunter here
well I think first of all it's very
interesting that this now based upon
what the mark Little League attorney for
The Whistleblower is saying this is
going to come down to credibility
because he is alleging that this guy is
not political one way or the other and
you know we've seen whistleblowers come
and go and they're kind of touched or
involved in politics I like the way this
sounds it's up to the Inspector General
for the Department of Justice to make a
decision as to whether or not this guy
is going to be given whistleblower
status which you absolutely need with
this Administration but the what's
interesting is that he is a senior uh
person in the IRS and he claims to have
a lot of evidence that's not just based
upon believe me and not him here's the
evidence here's the documents here's the
emails and let me say one more thing he
says that he has information that
contradicts a highly appointed uh
political appointee in the Biden
Administration and it appears that he is
going to contradict what America and the
Attorney General said before the Senate
Judiciary Committee when he said I have
pledged not to interfere with the
investigation I have carried through on
my pledge now if the Whistleblower is
credible and relies on documents is not
political and gets that whistleblower
status then for one of the few times
that we've wondered about this guy for a
long time when he called parents a
domestic terrorist it's time to take a
real good look at this guy mayor Garland
and his politicization of the Department
of Justice no grand jury investigation
takes five years okay 2018 to 2023
that's nonsense then we talked about
polls President Biden is doing great but
his best uh spokesperson out there says
you know what don't talk to us talk to
the IRS or the Department of Justice so
the press secretary a few weeks ago in
March she was uncharacteristically broke
the seal and she was the first time ever
that she had commented on Hunter Biden
and the allegations against him saying
that it was a bunch of lies and bad
politics and at the time it was like oh
whoa was the White House now officially
going to be defending Hunter Biden now
they have a spokesperson at the White
House council's Office named em Sams
he's very good at what he does and
that's where you can send as a press
secretary you can say guys I want to
talk about the economy today you can
call Ian you got his number I don't have
anything for you on that that's the
right place to be and the safe place to
be for a press secretary she didn't go
there so the Press is right to be
skeptical and very interested to see
what this whistleblower has to say
because
it seemed like his attorney I don't know
what this guy is like in terms of The
Whistleblower but his attorney is sober
minded he has Clarity of purpose he says
this is my client I'm going to do my
best for him so let's listen to what he
has to say he'll be on Special Report
tonight uh on this Greg we're talking
about Hunter Biden I mean the charges
are the um investigation goes all the
way down to did he lie about drugs when
purchasing a gun ironically enough but
we're talking I think six Biden family
members all the way down to grandkids
nieces and nephews that uh um oversight
uh chairman James Comer is bringing you
up saying Hey listen uh all these people
are receiving money and at least Hunter
was on the board of an energy company
let's listen to what else he had to say
here about this
I don't see how Joe Biden could not be
compromised I mean these these family
members aren't energy experts they
weren't on boards at least with barisma
Hunter actually sat on a board there are
no other boards that we can find that
these family members sat on certainly
not the the grandchildren and the nieces
and the nephews and the in-laws and
things like that and so what were they
doing why were they getting this much
money the walls are closing in on the
Biden family ah is Joe Biden compromised
why did he have to say the walls are
closing out well don't say that
yeah yeah yeah yeah but the thing is
being good but when you when you talk
about this whole experience of the Biden
crime family you realize
you don't need a whistleblower
everything they do is like you're
looking at it you're going okay you
don't have to blow a whistle on the
illegal drug use or the whoring or the
gun charge or the even the financial
double dealing the selling of influence
I mean you don't need a whistleblower
with Hunter I mean you would literally
die yes he's been blowing his own
whistle no pun intended by and that's
also physically impossible
I still have that visual in my mind two
questions what were our two questions
someone had to report the income to the
government why hasn't one journalist
asked who's paying the taxes I think we
asked that a couple months ago follow
the money and that's what they're doing
now but the reporters are too busy
sniffing you know Trump's W-2s to care
the second question was who pushed the
who pushed the 50 Intel agent letter yes
who forced the agency that's a good
question yeah to sign that letter well
they I think they have an answer right
yeah it's my well Mike Morrell who's a
fellow spook and did he run uh yeah he
ran CIA yes and then he claims blinken
was the one while working for uh Biden
to I mean this is such deep State stuff
it's insane Herald off heard you say
things like the hunter Biden laptop is
more Canon fodder for politics than
something that's worth our time and
effort is this an investigation it's
worth congress's time but I didn't have
a set of as elegantly as you did I I
think uh put up or shut up Hunter Biden
five years judge you're absolutely right
five years money laundering uh taxes uh
lobbying are you telling me that the
best you have is another whistleblower
if there's a whistleblower why isn't he
a witness in the Delaware U.S attorneys
probe why isn't it a witness in one of
the criminal probes what's he doing
hanging around with politicians and it's
going to go up there and she doesn't
want to lose his job you lose his job
you know what about Hunter Biden has
been accused of the most vile things for
over five years
from the deputy attorney general in
order to indict him right
Trump appointed the U.S attorney in
Delaware not Biden
yeah and Biden has kept him on and under
Garland Hunter is unwell uh maybe we'll
hear what he has to say I hope he has a
lot to say myself all right stay tuned
the IRS whistleblowers attorney is on
Special Report tonight hi winner Brian
Kilmeade I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now